it's not it's a first speaker in the off
the Marian is Mahdi Israel all right all
right so it's a real pleasure to be here
I'm excited to take part in one of these
workshops thank you to the organizers
for inviting me it's it's really
wonderful I am the second speaker and
basically a session that we have on
thinking about the visual system and the
role that the thalamus serves along with
the cortex and how those two structures
work intimately together to guide
cortical function and and the processing
of visual information so a my talk I
what I took a few slides out actually so
that we could get a more interactive if
we go down that path so hopefully we can
I work in the early visual system namely
the retina that lines the back of the
eye the lateral geniculate nucleus and
the primary visual cortex and as I'm
sure everybody in the room knows retinal
ganglion cells and their axons to target
cells in the geniculate these are the
relay cells that then send their axons
to primary visual cortex and this
pathway as I've described it is the feed
forward path way it's the convey its
conveying signals from the eye up to the
cortex in this feed forward direction
now in the visual system there is also a
very dense feedback pathway where
neurons and primary visual cortex and
axons back to the Janicki lair and it's
this interaction of feed-forward and
feedback pathways that govern largely
governed the response properties of
neurons in the LGN and how they
influence the the activity of these
cells will ultimately determine the
signals that will make their way to
cortex so if we can get a sense for how
these feed-forward and feedback pathways
interact we can have a much better
understanding of the nature of the
signals and how they can be dynamically
influenced as those signals propagate
from retina to cortex okay so the
question that I want to address today is
namely how do these feed-forward and
feedback pathways interact during visual
processing and this slide is a little
bit more detail of a circuit diagram
it's a little bit of an
oversimplification but we have the
retina with the axons projecting to the
lateral geniculate nucleus those axons
going up to cortex there's some
intrinsic circuitry and the cortex is
going to further process those signals
but importantly we have that feedback
pathway okay so we have the feed-forward
input to the geniculate that feedback
pathway to the Jenek youlet and there's
a few facts that we have to you know all
understand to to be able to move forward
with thinking about how these pathways
interact so one really striking finding
is that retinal ganglion cells their
synapses constitute only five to ten
percent of the total number of synapses
on to geniculate cells so it's the
minority of inputs that are that are
coming from the retina to to drive
responses into the geniculate if you
look at this feedback pathway more than
50% of the synapses onto those same
cells come from the feedback projections
so just based from an anatomical
perspective or thinking about it in
terms of the numbers you would think
this feedback pathway is doing all of
the work but there's some things that we
need to understand about these these
synapses to understand that one is a
driving source of input and the other is
what we believe to be a modulatory
source of input so these inputs coming
from the retina these are very large
synapses compared to the feedback
synapses which are much smaller these
are located more proximally on the
dendritic arbors of Janicki lit cells
where the feedback
synapses are more peripherally and also
the feed-forward under those synapses we
have exclusively ionotropic receptors
were in the feedback pathway it's a
combination of ionotropic and
metabotropic
so there's some definite differences
between the synapses provided from the
feed floor than feedback pathways that
we need to think about when we're
thinking about what roles these pathways
serve now another important point could
make is that this feedback projection
has the opportunity to have both a
monosynaptic excitatory influence as
well as a die synaptic inhibitory
influence all of the neurons in that
lemak reticular nucleus are GABAergic so
this collateral that comes off of these
feedbacking axons that goes into the
chthonic nucleus
has the opportunity then to provide a
polysynaptic or die synaptic inhibition
okay now these this feedback pathway
originates from neurons and layer six of
visual cortex and at the end of the talk
I'll talk briefly about a pathway that
Murray brought up that cortical pulvinar
pathway just to compare and contrast the
influence of layer six feedback versus
layer five projections and the influence
that they have okay
all right so how can we study this
feed-forward projection so the first
part of the talk what I'd like to do is
focus on the feed-forward projections
from retina to lgn and then I'll turn
and talk about the feedback projections
so when we look at the feed-forward
projections there's a wonderful
preparation that one can do and the
anesthetized animal whereby you can
record from synaptically connected pairs
of cells and this isn't easy but it's
certainly doable and what makes it
doable is the fact that both structures
have a retinotopic map to them
so what's illustrated here is how one
goes about identifying pairs of cells
that are synaptically connected simply
put an electrode array into the Janicki
--let and then one can look at the
surface of the retina and when you look
at the surface of the retina this is the
vasculature here's an electrode this is
a little laser this is an experiment and
going on you can direct that laser to
find the region of the retina that
excites the cells that you're recording
from and then just manipulate your
electrode to touch down on that site
okay now that will put you in close
proximity so you can start asking
questions about are they connected or
not connected and I'll talk about how we
do that in just a moment to map the
cells receptive fields we use a variety
of stimuli a one stimulus that we use
quite often is a white noise stimulus
many of you in this room know the
stimulus very very well but some of you
may not
it looks like a checkerboard basically a
black and white pixels rapidly rapidly
changing between what's white and what's
black it's governed by an EM sequence
and when and this is a really nice
stimulus to use when you're mapping many
cells receptive field simultaneously
because as long as they're somewhere on
that screen you can get a nice receptive
field map of their spatial structure and
also with the influence that time has on
that as well okay and that that analysis
that we do I should just mention is a
reverse correlation analysis where for
every spike that
kurz from the cells that you're
recording from you just look back in
time and ask what was the stimulus that
preceded those spikes okay so this is
that preparation I mentioned just a
moment ago
here are two receptive field maps from
two cells recorded from simultaneously
one in the retina one in the lateral
geniculate nucleus our convention is for
regions of the the stimulus that would
excite the cell when the pixels were
white are indicated in red so these
would be on sub regions regions of the
stimulus that would excite the cells
when they were black they're indicated
in blue so those would be off sub
regions so these are very stereotypical
on center off surround receptive fields
and even though they're shown
side-by-side here again they correspond
to the same area of visual space this
circle drawn over the retinal ganglion
cell that same exact circle as shown
superimposed over the Janicki lip
receptive field okay so receptive field
receptive field similarity doesn't
necessarily mean the cells are connected
so to assess connectivity we can do a
cross correlation analysis where we're
basically just looking at the spike
trains of the two cells and asking
what's the relationship between them so
in this case you take the retinal
ganglion cell spike train set them to
time zero look before and after each
retinal spike and ask what did the
Janicki lit cell do and for cells that
are mono synaptically connected you see
this very abrupt peak in their cross
correlogram it shifted to the right of
zero by about three and a half to four
milliseconds a very steep rise to it and
you have that when you're using say a
drifting grading stimulus a white noise
stimulus like we see up above or even if
you just have the animal sitting on the
dark and you're measuring
spontaneous activity okay so what do we
find well here are just as many
receptive fields I could fit on one
screen where we have the retinal
ganglion cell receptive field to the
left of the LGN neurons receptive field
all of these were cell pairs that were
monosynaptic ly connected and you can
see that they look remarkably similar to
each other so there's and this is
already pretty well known the receptive
fields of genicular neurons in the cat
are very similar to those other retinal
inputs nevertheless we can quantify the
extent of their similarity and also the
strength of the connection with a few
values so to
compare their similarity we can do a
normalized dot product where we just
look at the two cells receptive field
maps if they're perfectly overlap same
sign they'd get a value of one perfectly
overlap but opposite and sign say an on
center over and off center cell that
would be minus one and as they start to
pull apart you approach zero
contribution here is a measure of
strength of connection so this is the
percentage of the Janicki lat cell
spikes that were driven or evoked from
that simultaneously recorded retinal
ganglion cell okay and to make it really
easy all it literally is is the number
of spikes in the peak of the cross
correlogram divided by the total number
of Janicki at spikes that's your
contribution value okay so when you do
that what you find is that and and I
should mention that the green asterisks
correspond to cell pairs that were
deemed to be connected and the pink
circles here were cell pairs that were
not connected okay and there's two
take-home messages from this one as the
receptive fields become more and more
similar there's an increase in the
probability of connectivity and as they
become more and more similar there's an
increase in that strength of connection
and you know you can go back and forth
in terms of what's determining the other
more likely it's a strength of
connections that's determining the
degree of similarly similarity between
the receptive fields okay so this is
basically a background to to illustrate
that the retina is is the driving force
to the Janicki lit cells that the
receptive fields of those Janicki light
cells are very very similar to the
retinal inputs all right so why have a
lateral geniculate nucleus why is it
there if they're not going to do
anything in terms of transforming the
spatial structure receptive fields what
is it doing and we were interested in
what it might be doing in the temporal
domain what might it be doing in terms
of filtering those incoming retinal
spike trains to selectively pass some
spikes to cortex but not others that's
where I want to go next so if you look
at any given pair of cells one thing
that always stands out is that the
retina fires at a much higher rate than
does the lateral geniculate nucleus
cells okay their target cells so some
spikes will get through others don't and
that raises the question of is there a
difference between those that will evoke
a response
and those that won't so to tackle this
question what we did was to take all the
spikes from a given retinal ganglion
cell and just sort them into two
categories those that would evoke a
response and those that did not
if you evoked a response that signal
gets relayed up to cortex if you don't
read evoke a response that signal was
lost okay
now these are two pools of spikes so we
would and they're not going to be
exactly matched in number so whichever
group had the more spikes we would just
subsample that so that we would have
spike count match datasets and we did
that because then we could run the
spikes through the reverse correlation
analysis and look at the optimal
stimulus for them and that's what we see
below here so what we can do now is
directly compare the brightness of these
pixels and that gives you an indication
of the correlation between the stimulus
and and the spiking behavior of the cell
so the spikes that are relayed to cortex
has stronger receptive field Maps then
the spikes that aren't relayed another
way to view it is that there's we're
getting rid of more of the noise spikes
at the synapse and retaining those
spikes that are that are telling us
something about the stimulus yeah right
so what you find is that the same
retinal spike can often drive
synchronous spikes in the pair and I
don't have time to go into it now but
what's special about those synchronous
spikes is they're really they're
synergistically interacting with each
other to drive the cortical target cells
because they arrive simultaneously in
time to their target cells in the cortex
yeah great question
I mean how often do you see enough genes
bike that doesn't have a great question
it depends on the species that you're
looking at so if you're looking at cat
that number is not a hundred percent if
you're looking at monkey it is okay and
that's just because I'm cat there's
convergence of somewhere between
sometimes they're single-cell inputs but
typically it's two to five we're in the
monkey it's one to one and in that
monkey then every single LGN cell spike
is believed to be evoked by a retinal
spike which right there would tell you
that the other inputs are that's not
quite exactly true when when you look at
bursts in the LGN but that's a whole
other topic that we can touch upon maybe
in discussion yeah that's what you go to
just simply through a random percentage
of a random fraction well remember
there's the exact same number of spikes
that went into these maps okay so in the
case on the Left more of those spikes
were consistently associated in this
case with a white pixel on the center
were over here it was a smaller fraction
of those total spikes was associated
with a white pixel in the center they
could have been associated with a black
pixel in the center okay all right so if
you just want to use there's many ways
you can quantify this one way would just
be to look at the center amplitude
between the relay to non relayed spikes
so the relay to non relayed and you see
across cell pairs that the amplitude is
greater for the relayed cell spikes you
can also do an information theoretic
analysis and let's just look calculate
the bits per spice and see that they're
carrying more bits to the cortex as well
on average so the LGN some people call
it a dumb relay I'd say it's a very
smart relay it's picking off these more
informative spikes to to relate to
cortex now
let's see here uh let's see I'm running
jeez I'm running fast short on time fast
so I am going to skip these things here
and just basically bring up how would
the geniculate know which spikes are
more informative they you know a spike
is a spike they have an all or nothing
you're all or nothing event they should
look the same and their spatial
structured according to them they don't
quite exactly but nevertheless what
mechanism might underlie this and what
we decided to look at was the temporal
structure of the spike train in
particular what role the interspike
interval between spikes might play ok
odds are an interaction that you would
see between spikes based on how far
apart they are when they would arrive to
the Geneva itself and what you find is
that's indeed the case here we're just
looking at two different stimulus
conditions and drifting grading or white
noise and if you look at a pair of
spikes okay the first bike in the second
spike of a pair as they vary in
interspike interval so you pull them
further and further apart in time you
see that those second spikes are more
effective than this first bikes out to
about 30 milliseconds so very consistent
with the notion of temporal summation
okay that when these spikes arrive close
in time they can summit with each other
and drive that postsynaptic cell what's
interesting about that is that the time
course of this nicely fits the time
course for the more informative spikes
so here we just look at the distribution
of interspike intervals for 20 different
retinal ganglion cells and again if you
do that analysis I described were you
sub sample so that you're using the
exact same number of spikes across all
of these different is is you find that
it's the shortest is ice spike then that
has the the best correlation with the
visual stimulus okay so just to run over
these points real fast
retinal spikes that occur within 30
milliseconds of a previous bike are
better at driving geniculate neurons
those following short is-is are more
frequently evoke by the visual stimulus
carry more information and this last
part is what i think is interesting is
that the whatever the biophysical
properties that govern temporal
summation and spike generation in the
LGN appear to be tuned in that they have
the same time course to capture those
most informative spikes leaving the
retina okay so what about the feedback
pathways now remember we have
monosynaptic excitation and die synaptic
inhibition that's present
if you compare this is just a retinal
ganglion cell and LGN cell that are
connected this is a hundred trials of
presenting 300 milliseconds of a
stimulus to them and you can see that
you know of course the LGN cell is
producing fewer spikes than the retinal
cell did but there's the opportunity to
turn up that transfer or turn down that
transfer of retinal spikes that's where
I want to go with this so we decided to
use jaws as a method to inactivate the
cortical genicular pathway this is so
this is using a virus approach so we use
the AAV virus with a human synapse and
promoter and that drives a halorhodopsin
okay and that's the jaws and what makes
it jaws is that it's is that it's
sensitive to red wavelength light that
gives us better penetration into deeper
tissues so on the left here we're just
looking at it also has GFP coupled to it
so we're looking at the expression of
the jaws down or the GFP here down to
the deeper layers we make these
injections trying to focus on deeper
layers this is just blowing this up and
you can even label axons in the Janicki
light which is cool because you could
turn off those cortical inputs also by
putting a fiber optic into the LG and if
you want to okay so this is just to show
you that this is a very effective way of
silencing the cortex two different cells
shown here laser goes on on the left
this is a drifting grating that's why we
see these periodic bursts of activity
for that cortical cell when you turn on
the red light the cortical activity goes
down to next to nothing over here
another cell this is a standing
stationary stimulus you turn on the
light the spontaneous activity goes down
you turn on the stimulus and in the
presence of red light you get next to no
response so very effective means of
turning off the cortex transiently and
repeatedly so what do you see in the
Janicki later okay this slide is really
important this but it's also pretty busy
what we're doing here is we're moving
we're recording from a jeannette cell
and then moving a fiber-optic around in
the cortex so that we can turn off
different regions of cortex relative to
where the receptive field of the
geniculate cell is so in these cases
here the geniculate cells receptive
field is at the center here and then the
position of the fiber-optic relative to
that in retinotopic space is indicated
by these letters the important part here
in the top series of panels these are
all conditions where the
fiberoptic and the Janicki Lascelles
receptive field were in close retina
topic register down below this is when
they were further apart spatially and
retina top further apart retina
topically when they are overlapping and
each and every case what you find is
that when you turn on the light the
firing rate of the Janicki light cell
goes down that means we're removing
excitation or net excitation whereas
when you're further away the firing rate
goes up when you silence the feedback
pathways okay
indicating that you're removing net
inhibition and when you put all of this
together what you end up with is a very
nice center surround organization to
feedback where it looks like feedback
that's retina topically aligned as net
excitatory and that which is further
away becomes net suppressive and this
last case over here is is the furthest
away where you see no influence of the
feedback pathway yeah so in this case
here the receptive field sizes were
about three degrees and these all fall
within that sort of three degrees own
okay so the implications of this which I
just don't have time to go into but it
certainly has strong implications for
extra classical suppression that is
there's a zone surrounding cells
receptive fields were stimulated that
fall into that will suppress a neurons
activity for gain control as well covert
attention where you mentally attend to
different regions of space and also
shifting cells in and out of bursts and
tonic activity modes and maybe we can
discuss some of that later okay five
minutes oh I'm not as bad off as I
thought
okay so I've alluded to the fact that
the feedback from the cortex isn't going
to be driving responses but we can still
look for that and we can look for that
by recording from an LG n cell while
simultaneously monitoring its retinal
input and asking what happens and you
can do that when you can this is a great
thing about the Janicki ilat is that you
can record both action potentials and S
potentials as potentials are these small
deflections that actually represent the
an extracellular measure of the epsp
that's coming from the retina so in this
particular case here you're recording
from the janila cell these are the s
potentials up above you turn on the
laser you see no influence on the s
potential
but the Janicki let cells firing goes
down okay that's fine but what we can do
is ask how did it affect that transfer
of spikes and that's what's shown to the
right here so this is retinal efficacy
it's a percentage of retinal spikes that
would evoke trigger a Janicki lit
response and you can see that efficacy
drops by a little bit more than half and
you turn off the feedback pathway so
we're we're the Terp rotation being your
hyperpolarizing the self fewer of those
retinal spikes get through now last
slide data slide that i have for you
here is comparing the influence of
cortical input to the Janicki light
versus cortical input to the pulvinar
nucleus
okay so we've already seen these two
panels over here this was a case where
we see that feedback when you remove it
you suppress it activity goes down
here's the case where it goes up the
important thing is here we're modulating
the activity we're not completely
turning it off turning off those Janicki
lit cells on the right this is a case
now where we silenced the cortical
pulvinar axons and in this case we're
doing it we don't want to turn off v1
for this we want to turn off those axons
as they're going into the pulvinar
nucleus so we're putting the fiber-optic
into the pulvinar and here so this is
the situation here the laser goes on
then we turn on the visual stimulus in a
controlled condition there's this nice
evoked response from the pulvinar cell
but when the when the when the jaws is
stimulated you turn off the cell and
that pulvinar response drops completely
to 0 okay that pulvinar cell cannot
respond without the input that comes
from v1 so definitely indicative of a
driver input over here on the right this
is now because these pulvinar cells are
sort of unique and special that they can
have very complex receptive fields
relative to what a Janicki ilat is
Janicki --let receptive fields are nice
center surround the pulvinar has
receptive fields that in many ways look
like cortical receptive fields and this
was the cells receptive field it was a
nice orientation selective cell we've
seen plenty of Direction selective cells
and even sells his receptive fields
we're struggling to even figure out
what's the optimal stimulus for them
indicating and likely convergence from
from multiple areas but in all these
cases with what's neat about this is
this is a method i would call it like
opto tagging
okay we're using optogenetics to tell
you that you've identified a cell that's
getting input from a particular
structure and then you can ask what are
the receptive field properties of that
so two things here you can see that that
v1 input is critical for that cells
activity and also you can identify those
cells to get a sense of what's what are
the response properties of cells in the
pulvinar that get input from a cortical
area which is something that's eluded us
for so long in the pulvinar because it's
such a heterogeneous structure okay so
just to wrap up what we've seen is that
retinal ganglion cells produce many more
spikes than their target neurons in the
Jenek youlet that the LGN relays the
most informative spikes the cortex that
the communication could be enhanced or
suppressed by feedback that when the
feedbacks from retina topically aligned
regions it provides a net excitation
when it comes from regions further away
its net suppression and then lastly that
the projections modulate geniculate
activity while projections to the
pulvinar drive the pulvinar activity and
with that this is just my group at davis
that contributed to the experiment so
thank you very much
[Applause]
strange that you don't make all that
they've written then just throw away
some of the spikes and so I'm wondering
there ought to be some situations for
each all the spikes commander well a
great question
you know one thing that I would say for
folks that study the retina this notion
that the brain wants to conserve ATP
doesn't apply to the retina ya know I
mean they there seems to be no
hesitation to produce a lot of spikes
and when you think about it you know
it's a funny situation if the stimulus
is bright half the cells are active if
it's dark the other half are active when
you euthanize an animal and you're
recording from like the Janicki let the
retina the cortex altogether the cortex
disappears the thalamus disappears in
the retina keeps going it does it
doesn't want to give up producing spikes
for some odd reason so I take your point
that you know that you would think that
maybe every spike should get through in
a certain situation but nobody's ever
found that at least not in mammals that
I'm aware of in the cortex which are
centered on the receptive field of the
LGN you run then you decrease the
spiking
silence that cortical neuron which are
all fun but you'd agree to the center of
the receptive field of the time it
nearly facilitate the time injure
another two possible circle one is a
circuit in which you actually use a beam
rt1 is an intricate circuit maybe
silencing those cortical neuron which
are off-center are going to facilitate
them to other cortical neurons which are
on center through a locus around the
suppression so which one yeah that's a
really clever idea which I hadn't
thought about so I think maybe I'll have
to think about this but one approach
might be for that would be to move your
fiber-optic rather than moving it around
the cortex move it around within the
Janicki let relative to the cells
receptive field that might solve that
but I have to think about a little but
it's a good point illustrating my
ignorance of the anatomy is there
exactly one connection from ganglion
cells every LGN cell or there I thought
there were multiple converging ganglion
cells when he tells you itself ok good
question it depends on the species so in
the cat there are it's generally
somewhere in the neighborhood of like
two to four cells converging in terms of
at least having effective connectivity
driving responses and the monkey it is
one-to-one
so given geniculate cells believed to
get input from just one right I'll get
your informative spikes are actually
synchronous spikes you sort of mentioned
that from the LGN the coincident spikes
are driving v1 very nicely at this super
linear way is it possible the same story
is true and you're just you're measuring
information but what you're actually
seeing as a result of synchrony or so
that would be synchrony then within the
retina right okay and that's form of
synchrony there are there have been some
measures of that form of synchrony that
tends to occur primarily through gap
junction coupling in the retina which is
something that you see with Y cells in
the retina and not the X cells in and we
find this in both the X and the y
pathways
milliseconds right and you're saying the
set of spikes that propagate through the
ones that are approximately like you're
getting these 30 milliseconds yes so if
you imagine the probability of getting
another spike from another ganglion cell
was higher for at the time where they're
sustainable yep driving that so I know
where you're coming from so I think how
do I would explain that from the plots
that I showed you was that when I when I
showed you this plots where the x-axis
was the interspike interval those first
spikes of the pair never had an efficacy
of zero
they were elevated up some and that's
probably likely that they're coming on
the heels of a spike from another
retinal ganglion cell if you did that
same plot and the monkey those those
first spikes would would have an
efficacy of zero yeah good question okay
so that it's a bit of a paradox when you
show it about Palmer v1 that Hogan our
activity depends on v1 activity but also
v1 activity depends on Palmer activity
so in some sense they're bootstrapping
themselves up sustained activity you
know that's an interesting we were just
discussing that at lunch okay the study
that indicated that the pulvinar is
essential for v1 activity and at our
lunch table we came to the conclusion
that that that was a an ambitious
statement and that rather if you look at
the data more closely it really looks
like the pulvinar is modulating v1
activity okay yeah that's what what I'm
referring to
that's that was that was our conclusion
yes and our that that really without me
one Pulver not really goes to zero
that's right that's right and what I can
say for those I didn't have any data for
this but we have been doing the
recordings in v1 when we turn off the
the axons entering the pulvinar from v1
and we don't see in our hands we don't
see a change in the firing rate of v1
cells what we find is that the spike
field coherence drops dramatically
indicating that whatever is driving that
field let's call it you know correlated
ensemble activity network activity that
there's that the pulvinar is is
decreasing that that that sort of maybe
community synchrony that you would see
when the pulvinar is removed that's a
big stretch to take but certainly the we
don't see the the cortex going silent no
that was silencing v1 the example I
showed was the fiber-optic in v1 yeah I
think you might be thinking I showed a
lot but but when you saw the cortex v1
go silent that was with the fiber-optic
in v1 and when you saw the pulvinar go
silent that was with the fiber-optic in
the pulvinar
okay I think we should it's all right
next car is firing bricks